nay khá nhiều
khá nhiều việc đầ xuất nhưng mà cái quan
trọng đó là à Tôi cảm thấy vẫn cân lên
on để mà đây sẽ đương nhiên là mấy ông
vẫn thấy là
tôi thích hơi thích việc tâm sự nhiều
hơn việc dạy nhưng mà nó không phải về
mọi tâm sự mà theo tôi nó vẫn là cái gì
đó gọi là chia sẻ góc nhìn của mình vậy
vì tôi sắp chia sẻ cho mấy ông rất nhiều
cái cũng C nghĩ là nó là một cái những
cái bài học gì gì đó n n giống như là
hôm qua tôi vừa xem anh đổ kể về vụ là
An Đổ vừa mới bị hah kênh nh Vy lần nữa
đấy thì anh đấy coi Đấy là một bài học
xứng máu của anh đấy để làm vương cho
mọi người né ra tôi nghĩ là tôi có vài
bài học gì đó để thể chia sẻ cho mọi
người vì tôi tôi chia sẻ Thế thì mấy ông
cũng hỏi th Nói chung là nó lan tỏa thôi
việc đó chia sẻ cộng nhìn của tôi và bài
học của tôi thì tôi muốn mọi người cũng
chia sẻ với nhau Nhữ các thứ th thế rồi
chúng ta sẽ cùng giúp nhau vượt qua Vân
Vân đúng không ạ Nếu mà ai cũng giữ ra
riêng mình thì ai cũng phải học cái bài
học ấy thì nó đắt quá đúng không
ở công ty ở Trưng thì sao thế quên tận
hai con chuột th ra bây giờ tôi đang
dùng chuột laptop mà may hôm nay cũng
chẳng mồi COD gì cả màu mà màu nói thôi
nhưng chả không cần chuột
lắm Tôi đang định à nói
Từ
Ừ
thôi hôm nay sẽ định nói hết đấy định
hôm nay sẽ nói hết toàn bộ những cái này
còn
về còn về cái A mấy cái link này thì tôi
nghĩ là khi lấy lại được l
Facebook ra khi mở khóa Facebook
Facebook tôi vẫn đã bị quá thì tôi sẽ
chia sẻ lại lên fanpage hay gi gì đó
xong rồi tôi xóa h link ha sau n mấy ông
Nếu mà tiện thì m ông có thể bấm vào xem
qua xem Ừ có cái gì mà anh lại g lại
đúng không
ạ Đầu tiên thì à
Ồ lâu lắm tôi tôi ghi cái này từ lâu rồi
Kiểu gi đọc lại không nhớ được không nhớ
được lắm để tôi nhớ ý chính xem
ạ Cái này là quan điểm chung
gì gặ bảo hiểm
giản lắm nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy là nó
biến thành một cái chên lý gì đó đó là
hôm đấy gương của xe máy tôi nó bị lọc
không biết mấy ông tôi tôi tôi thấy là
ít người dùng gương ở trên xe máy hoặc
người ta dùng hơi đối phó một tí nhưng
với tôi thì tôi cá nhân tôi tôi dùng
gương khá nhiều Và đặc biệt đặc biệt cái
hồi mà tôi bị ngã xe ấ tay tay trái bị
bị gãy nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy may mắn vẫn
còn may mắn một tí đó là cái gương của
xe nó cũng chống phần nào cũng cho tôi
Đặc biệt năm năm sau cơ Ôi cũng gần đến
dịp đấy rồi tôi cảm thấy là cứ đến tháng
tư rồi như là đây bị bị xui xẻo không
tôi Tôi không tin vào tôi không m tín
lắm nhưng nói chung là cũng cũng đúng
ngay hôm vừa rồi cũng cũng mới tấm Trư
cũng bị
à bị kiểu
ọc đến thật
29 tháng 4 À hồi năm nhất đại học của
tôi Tôi bị ngã gậy tay TC xĩ đâ h đấy
thì à xe xe Hình như hồi đấy xe không có
gương hay gương gì gì đó không nhớ chố
bị gãy tay đấy Xong rồi Một năm sau đúng
ngày 30 tháng 4 tôi lại ngã
cũng cũng do né một ông taxi Năm ngoái
thì ông taxi lao vào tôi bởi vì hồi đ
tôi đi rất là chậm ông ấy vượt qua xong
rồi ông ấy kéo xe tôi thèo tôi Mị Ngã
Năm nay thì tôi đang tôi ấy đang đi
nhanh xe đột nhiên nó đổi hướng nên tôi
phải phanh gấp rồi
tôi kiểu nói chung là phanh gấp hết sức
có thệ nên thành ra bị xòe đấy May may
Năm May Hồi đấy gương nó cứng hơn tí nó
đỡ hở cho tôi nên không bị ấm sao cả n
tôi càng cảm thấy là cái gương nó cứu
tôi được mấy Pháp nên là tôi cũng khá là
cẩn thận về cái việc gương xe các thứ
thử đấy Thì đại khái thì quay lại câu
chuyện này đó là hôm đấy hương tôi bị
lọc Tôi nghĩ là hay là do Hương mua lâu
cũ quá rồi nó bị đỏng nhở Hay mình đang
định làt sop thì đổi cái mới thì tôi
mang ra hàng sởi xe để bảo dưỡng và và
thử vặn lại gương cho em xem được
không Bởi vì mấy ông biết mấy ông biết
là có cái cái gương nó có đây tra thử
sạch cho m ông hỉ dung gương xe
này
nháy hình ảnh này đi đây mấy ông biết
cái chỗ này lỏng lỏng đúng không ạ thì
vặn được nhưng mà cái A cái nào
nhỉ Cứ cho cái đoạn này đi cái đoạn đoạn
đoạn này CH biết dùng từ cái gì đây có
hình này dễ h đây cái lỏng chỗ này vặn
được nhá thì tôi biết nó có í Ở đây vn
vặn đúng không Nhưng cái đoạn này lỏng
cơ cái đoạn ở đây lỏng cơ không có cái
hình nào gì gần giống hơn
đây Cái cái đoạn này của tôi lúc đấy bị
lỏng cơ thế Tôi nghĩ là chắc là cái này
phải thay hướng với rồi đấy xong tôi
đang định là sopy đấy thì lúc mà tôi
mang xe ra bảo dưỡng thì ờ hóa ra là
người ta cũng chỉ cần vặn Ở đây có một
cái vi nhỏ ở đây hay gì gì đó người ta
vặn vào cái này được Nhưng mà mình mới
cảm thấy
là mình đang bị tư duy đó là ước cái gì
cái mình nghĩ ngay Việc đổi mở chứ mình
không hề nghĩ việc sửa nó
không hề nghĩ đến việc ấy luôn Mình cứ
nghĩ là ô có khi đổi mới dễ hơn và có
khi chỉ có cách duy nhất là đổi mới đấy
không hề nghĩ việc sửa luôn không biết
là do từ ba gi tôi bắt đầu xem lại quan
điểm của
mình hay là từ trước nay mình có mình qu
điểm thế có khia rất nhiều cái mình
không th nghĩ Vic xưa t mình nĩ phệt thô
có có mới nớ cũ đúng không vân vân cả
trong mối quan hệ tình cảm có thể thấy
thật vân vân biết mấy ông có nghĩ thế
thôi Hay mấy ông mà chưa có nghĩ bao giờ
không chắc được nhưng mà đại khái thì
tôi tôi từ một cái chuyện nhỏ thôi tôi m
nghĩ thế đấy
Ờ kiểu mình phải xem xét lại cái suy
nghĩ của
nhớ xem tại sao tôi lại ghi trữ bảo hiểm
trong
ng nó hơi bị kiểu ngắn gọn quá hơ khó
hình dung nhớ là hai cái này có liên
quan đến nhau nữa cơ xem nào để tôi chém
gió một cái gì đó liên quan đến nhau thì
có thôi Kiểu bảo hiểm xe máy hay cái gì
gì đó Ừ không biết mấy ông có mua bảo
hiểm xe máy h không
nữa tôi có mua
đấy đấy bả hình bắp thuộc mà mua không
hiểu từ CH dù rõ ràng rằng là
à mình hiy vọng là chẳng ai
muốn được chỉ trả bảo hiểm cả thường có
vấn đề gì đó phải chỉ trả vào hiểu đúng
không ạ
Thôi các ta bỏ qua cái vộ này đã tiếp
theo có một cái quan điểm này t ghi lại
đó là có nên đập đi làm lại Cúc hổ lốn
của người khác mấy ông a làm đập trình
thì mấy ông kiểu hình dung rồi Kiểu
Nếu mà vào lúc mà nó mới tinh thì không
sao vào mà lúc mà nó đã có cái gì đó rồi
thì là code người khác nó không theo cái
luồng của mình hiểu lắm mình nhiều người
code lũm
thuộm nhiều rất nhiều không phải không
đúng không ạ đế Tôi cũng thế rồii Tôi
cũng thừa nhận tôi là code đôi khi là ôi
Chiều nay tôi cũng vừa ngồi cch nhau với
sếp tôi luôn mà đó là em cấp nhận là
đoạn này code này có khi là gần như là
người không không phải là người duy nhất
sửa được là em nhá nói chung là người ta
mà vào sửa người ta sẽ sẽ kểu sẽ phải
hơi khó hiểu một
tí em cảm thấy là đoạn hô này em là
người sễ dễ sửa nhất và khác đấy C nhận
là như thế
thì nhưng mà để mà nói
thì đấy thì Nghĩa là đọc code người khác
rất là khó chịu kiểu như thế nên rất
nhiều lúc người ta mình thường anh có
suy nghĩ nó n là dùng cái trên thôi Đó
là kiểu thay vì mình ngồi sửa hay mình
đập đi đập lại đối khi là người ta cân
nhắc vi đập đi đập lại th
đậu dễ hiểu nhanh nhanh hơn chắc
thế nhưng mà ở đây không nói về bài toán
là việc là đập đi Nó có thể sai nhá thậm
chí là sai nhá Bởi vì có rất nhiều
code Hồi trước không biết kể cho mấy ông
V khái niệm đó
là đó
là có những cái code rõ ràng có những
cái
logic logic tồn tại trong code đấy nó
hơi chích chích một tí nó hơi mẹ mẹ thế
kiểu dạng là nó gọi là logic ẩn ấy m
không Không biết Không biết m không biết
khái niệm thì không nĩ rõ ràng là ví dụ
cùng một tính năng này nhưng mà thôi
thêm một t tính năng khác bởi vì là hồi
đấy nó gặp cái vấn đề này hoặc làm thế
này cho tiện ghép luôn hai cái tính năng
vào trong cái tính năng đấy th rõ ràng
tên của tính năng Đấy là tính năng Ví dụ
là tính năng kêu là à tạo đơn hàng đi
chả đấy Nhưng mà thực ra là nó còn lưu
thêm vài thông tin trong của mấy cái
bảng Chả liên quan nữa đấy không phải t
làm mỗi đơn hàng đấy sao tự nhiên ông
đập đi ông lại ông làm mỗi tinh giác tạo
đơn hàng thi chứ Vì sao tự nhiên phát
phát sinh là lỗi đấy Không hiểu tại sao
hó ra là
hó ra là kiểu ờ hồi đấy làm nó thêm thêm
một vài cái logic Ân trong đấy nữa
đấy thì tôi không nói về cái vụ đập đi
nó thể gây hại như nào như thế Tôi nói
về việc là xếp tôi thử cũng từng nói đó
là thực ra là em em nhìn code người khác
khó chịu thì ngược lại người ta nhìn
code của em cũng sẽ có thể thấy khó chịu
nghĩa là bản chất là ai cũng cố của ai
cũng sẽ là một mờ giác trong mắt người
khác thôi Nên là cái việc mà em đập đi
làm lại em nghĩ rằng Ừ code đấy trông
phải xị trông phải dễ nhìn hơn đấy nhưng
thực ra nó cũng sẽ là một cái đống giác
nào đó trong mắt của người sau thôi nên
thành ra là em phải cân nhắc việc Đánh
Đổi xem là em có nên biến mớ giáp của
người khác thành mớ giáp của mình không
nó chả giải quyết được thêm một cái gì
cả đấy Nói chung là sếp tôi thường hay
đánh các sếp mà nên thường hay đánh mạnh
về hiệu năng công việc hiệu suất công
việc Cái này có nên bó đáng thời bỏ thời
gian ra để làm không hay dùng thời gian
đấy giải quyết vấn đề khác đấy nếu mà
chỉ đơn giản là để cho mắt mình đỡ đau
mắt chỉ giải quyết mỗi vấn đề đấy thôi
thì không không nên làm Còn nếu mà thực
sự
là sửa nó xong để mà về sau mình dễ code
hơn để code nhanh hơn hay là bởi vì cái
đoạn đấy đang có phát sinh ra những cái
bấc tiềm ẩn à nó mình không thể xem sửa
được mình phải đập đi Đầm lại để mình
mình hạn chế nhất nhất có thể bớc thì nó
khác còn nếu đang chạy chạy rồi đúng
không ạ Các bạn biết cái chân lý đây là
gì ạ Cái gì đang Đang ổn rồi thì hãy để
nguyên nó đúng không ạ Đấy tốt nhất là
như
[âm nhạc]
nà đ
lng em thì không may mắn thế xe vạ gãy
xong h gương xe V gãy xong ông lao và
gương xe ô tô à Anh chỉ cách chạy TP
trên spch được không ạ
Ừ nếu mà em dùng Sach để mà chạy qua
file kiểu HTML bình thường thì chạy được
nó chạy Hẳng hơn trên rượt còn file pp
thì em sẽ phải gõ Hẳng đường dẫn ra các
thứ thì chạy chứ không chạy chuột phải
vào để chọn chạy được
đâu còn cách để chạy file pp thì cài môi
trường giống như kiểu sampi xong rồi
hoặc cả laon các thứ chứ Xẽ hướng dẫn
nhá chắc là trên YouTube có hóa dạy của
anh có dạy về trình pp cơ bản chẽ có
ờ không biết mấy ông có tôi tôi vẫn được
a đùa mấy ông ở mấy ông FA ở đây nhiều
không không biết đâ hiểu cảm giác hiểu
dằng khi Ừ thế cứ cho là mấy ông e Ba đi
mấy ông e ba thì kiểu gì cũng có người
mình từng thầm thương các thứ đúng không
ạ Đấy thì mấy ông có bao giờ vào xem
kiểu họ kiểu đang và họ lấy chồng mà
Thậm chí có có con các thứ thứ chưa đấy
hay chưa đến cả độ tuổi đấy thì tôi
không biết được
ờ đại khái Thì hôm trước tôi mới vào n
Tình Cờ thôi đó thấy kiểu Nhu người
người yêu cũ ới trông nhìn
K mình kiểu rất nhiều cảm xúc trong đấy
đặc biệt
là đấy thời gian không chờ đợi một ai cả
cảm thấy Ui
mình tại sao mình bây giờ vẫn còn thế
này ai thì kiểu hạnh phúc các thứ thứ
kiểu như là không thể nói là người ta đã
đến đích rồi nhưng mà người ta đã sang
hẳn một cái trang sách mới rồi cái con
đường mới rồi thì vẫn còn ở
đây thường con gái đương nhiên là cũng
trưởn thành sớm hơn mình đúng nhưng mà
tôi cảm thấy kiểu không biết mấy ông
thấy thế nào nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy mình
đang mình nhìn lại ấ mình là mình thấy
mình có vẻ mình đang chậm đang kiểu đang
chưa chưa trưởng thành kịp so với họ kể
thế họ trởng hành rồi họ đ gia đình rồi
th với tôi Nó là một cái đích một cái
tương đối là một cái đích đấy một cái
kiểu cứ cho là một cái đích đầu tiên đi
kiểu kiểu cứ Hình dung là kiểu cuộc đời
có một vài cái vạch đích nào đó để mình
phân đấu đến đúng không với tôi
thì đ đình là một cái cũng là một cái
đích thì họ đến đích trước rồi họ đi
sang cái trạng hai chạng ba đấy Mình thì
đang vẫn chưa được đến được cái đích đấy
thì nó không biết bao giờ đến được cái
đích
đấy cũng hơi sốt ruột Biết dùng từ như
nào
này mấy ông chưa gặp tình huống đấy á
cấp ba bây giờ lượt đề sang trang mới
đúng không Nhưng mà đau ở đây là không
phải đau màu cứ kiểu gì ý Kiểu người
từng đồng hành cùng mình đúng không ta
thì vẫn đang ngồi đây tâm sự không Toàn
đc
thân
nấy Tôi bảo là tiếng hôm nay sẽ để cái
tiêu đề này tâm sự tôi chập chững hôm
nay quên chưa đổi vậ đổi kịp không
nhỉ tôi đổi đi tôi đổi
đi hôm nay không có m trả lời câu hỏi s
tâm sự
Tuổi chập
chững
gặp Nếu cũ hay gì cơ hay là gặp bạn cấp
luôn Nói chung là hôm nay tôi muốn là
một buổi anh em mình ngồi tâm sự một
tí tâm sự kiểu
tình cảm đi ra vài mỗi chuyện tình cảm đ
nh không không nên chỉ dê Mội chỉ C
nhưng
thôi xem mấy ông quan điểm mấy ông thế
nào hình cũ không dục cũng đới học lớp
bắp nhau m ông yêu cùng lớp
à y thương mạ lớp mạ lấy chồng
Ừ đây nghĩ lại
event realtime được không
nó có hỗ trợ là kiểu giống như kiểu
Messenger thôi à không hoàn toàn là
Messenger dùng gì đại khái nó sẽ web
socket à Hay gì gì đó nó sẽ kểu nó luôn
stream
Ờ cái này chắc là bạn cứ không Phả chity
về công nghệ nhá Tôi chỉ nhớ là nó có
thể làm được tất C một thằng nó sẽ mở
cái kết nối và nó luôn đợi đợi tín hiệu
giống tôi nói giống Messenger ở điểm là
nó luôn đợi xem có tin nhắn mới đến hay
không ấy thì cái event kia khi mà xong
thì nó sẽ bắn cái sự kiện ra được để mà
thằng kia nó bắt nhưng mà với sự kiện
thằng kia phải luôn mở để bắt đấy đấy
theo như tôi hiểu thế Tôi chưa làm bao
giờ nhá Tôi tôi hiểu cái cơ chế kiểu của
NaNa
hồng m ông à không còn hồng nữa quên
không còn hồng hào gì nữa chúng ta nhìn
cuộc sống không còn là một hồng Hạo
Chúng ta đang ở Tôi dùng từ chập chững
bởi vì sao Bởi vì nếu mà theo góc nhìn
của tôi thì giống như là tôi bảo mấy ông
n đó là con gái tầm tầm tuổi tôi là 27
đúng không ạ Các bạn để có thể lập gia
đình rồi Nhưng mà thường cái tuổi của
anh em mình 27 tuổi thằng con trai thì
nó vẫn đang ở cái ngưỡng mà có thể đập
gia đình hoặc là vẫn còn chưa đủ chính
chắn chưa đủ vân vân vân mình vẫn nghĩa
là mình phải phấn đấu hơn nữa mình vẫn
hoàn thiện hơn nữa ví dụ là lên và nói
chung là nó nó vẫn chưa chến Buổi lắm ý
Kiểu tôi đang nghĩ là phải 30 m ch Tôi
định thế mới lập ra
đi Nghĩa là nghĩa là nó sẽ là kiểu nó sẽ
là kiểu như nào nhỉ Nó sẽ kiểu
là con trai một là cười sớm hẳn là kiểu
ha ba mới mới ra trường hai đứa kiểu còn
ngây thơ kiểu gọi là m bước chân chân
nước chân giáo vào đời đúng không đấy
với nhau đấy hoặc
là hoặc là mới ổn định tài chính một tí
kiu tấm 2 n đi đi làm 2 năm rồi TH có vẻ
tương đối ổn rồi cưới đấy còn tầm 27 28
như mình tôi tính ng ấy là tuổi Trực
chững nhất ấy đó nó công việc cũng có
Nhưng mà thực ra nó cũng chưa đủ Rất là
xịn vân vân đấy Nói chung là tôi cảm
thấy là cái tầm tuổi tôi hiện tại 27 28
hơi khó hơi khó bây giờ để lập gia đình
g Cùng lắm thì bây giờ kiếm ng yêu xong
đợi 2 năm nữa thì hợp thì lấy thô Chắc
thế chứ nó dở dở rang rang ấy phải không
hiểu nên là tôi mới dùng từ là chấp
thấy người bị tận hưởng sự cô đơn mới là
người tự do nhất vì mỗi người Mọi người
lên cách kiếm người yêu chư biết cái gì
Đúng em nói th rất là chuẩn xy nghĩ các
thứ thứ rồi Đúng là chuẩn chuẩn như mà
tôi thường hay đọc đó là hai người yêu
nhau ấy không phải hai người nên hoàn
toàn lụy với nhau và hai người không biệ
sống thiếu nhau chuẩn là hai cáo thể độc
lập có thể nói chung là vẫn có hạnh phúc
của riêng mình khi mà mình ở một mình
thôi Nhưng mà quan trọng là à hai người
đấy hoàn toàn thể tôn tôn đại phát triển
K dạng là tồn tại để hỗ trợ cộng cộng
sinh đúng một phần nhưng mà nói chung là
nhớ là có khái niệm là cộng sinh cng
sinh có những khái niệm gì nó khái niệm
kiểu dạng là cùng nhau phát triển nó
khác với kiểu là không để sống thiếu
nhau nhá khác nhau ấy mình đừng có bị
rơi vào tình trạng lụy quá mình kiểu là
Ngọ nhà
quan hệ mà kiểu tôi là người kể dạng là
cũng cố Cố kiểu chu cấp cũng kiểu cố
kiểu làm hết mọi thứ
nói tôi không biết làm tề nhà nhưng mà
đại khái
cũng chung cấp về mặt kinh tế Vân Vân
chẳng hạn đấy làm cho Và thậm chí là
kiểu Hồi đấy Công nhận là cũng chiều
cũng cố chiều các thứ thứ làm cho người
kia bị bị kiểu ỷ lại nhiều quá chắc thế
nên thành ra khi mà không không còn
trong mối quan hệ nữa thì người để bị
kiểu bị mất đi dần đi khả năng kiểu sinh
tôn ví dụ từ nhà đại khái thì bạn ấy khi
mà quay trở lại sống đ độp thân thì bấy
khá chật vật thế Lúc ấy tôi mới cảm thấy
th ng Khi mà mình làm mình tự nhiên lại
làm cho người ta bị bị yêu đua quá kểu
Thế bị rựa dẫm quá kểu thế đấy Nói chung
mình Không nên như thế đúng không ạ mình
nên Nói chung ai nên là nói nói
là tận ngược sự cô đơn thì nó kểu Hoa Mỹ
kiểu gì nhưng đại khái nó là kiểu Mình
phải trân trọng nhiều người bảo trân
trọng bản thân đã đúng không phải Trung
trọng và phải sống cho Toản thân đã lồ
có thể
kiểu biết được thực sự mình cần gì để
mà để mà giúp đỡ hỗ trợ người khác đúng
không Làm thế nào để nâng cao thiết kế
hệ thống kỹ năng thiết kế hệ thống
Ừ cái này lý thuyết là không đủ bạn ạ
Cái này bắt buộc là phải thực tế nhiều
thôi chứ bây giờ nói lý thuyết Kể cả bạn
học sách sách vân vân mình thấy là những
cái ông làm chuyên về thiết kế hệ thống
ấ ông ấy đều phải có năm kinh nghiệm chứ
không thể nào á cái lý thuyết xông và
được bởi vì ngay cả việc làm database
cũng thế database lý thuyết phải rất là
cũng tương đối nhá Nhưng
mà thực tế nó có rất là ắ điển hình ở
công ty mình là một điển hình nhá ví dụ
công ty mình đi không biết ví dụ đâu C
mình làm mới làm một công ty không biết
ví dụ đâu xa được đấy thì
việc thiết kế đ công ty mình đó là lúc
đầu thì mình về mình chê bởi vì là nó
không chuẩn hóa gì cả Có một bảng Nó chớ
thêm rất nhiều thông tin gọi là dư thừa
đấy Kiểu thế thì tôi bảo sao không cho
những b khác lấy dữ liệu tự nhiên mình
lưu hết vào trong bàng này thừa thê bng
gì X về sau nhận ra đấy làm flash
database Tức là mình hạ thế choin Mình
chấp nhận lưu thừa dữ liệu nhưng mà dữ
liệu đấy về sau nó cũng không thay đổi
Mình chấp nhận đều thừa C để về sau khi
mình lấy dữ liệu ra mình lấy từ một bảng
th vì cho th nhiều bảng nặng thì đấy
nghĩa là chị ạ Mình chấp nhận bài toán
tốn thêm chi phí một tí về tài nguyên
nhưng mà nó sẽ khiến ch làm nhanh hơn và
nó lại tốt hơn vài khía cạnh ởo đó đấy
nghĩa là mình lý thuyết đôi là thưa đủ
đúng không ạ mình phải áp dụng thực tế
mình phải hiểu được cái bài toán Được Và
Mất doanh nghiệp nó đặc biệt với cet nữa
thì phải luôn đề xuất được cet là là
Phương Hán A thì được cái này mất cái
kia Phương Hán B được cái này mất cái
kia chứ mình mà cơ theo kiểu cái quy
chuẩn cái chuẩn hóa nào đó mình cứ bảo
chỉ làm được cái A không thể làm được
cái b cái b chắc chắn sai thì mình lại
bị máy móc quá Mình
bị mình bị kiểu kiểu mình bị kiểu Chính
Mình đang tự đào hải chính mình vì mình
đang bị B th đấy lưu Nhược cột hơn hay V
Joy sang bảng khác đúng đúng đúng đúng
thế mic lạ ơ n không ai nói mic lạ có
khi là mic Nãy giờ đang dùng cái mic của
máy tính đây đúng không Thế mà nãy giờ
không ai tôi
alo được được chưa
ạ chắc nãy giờ m hôm kia có kh không
nghe
chưa n có cắm mic mà nà nhưng mà tôi
chắc là do máy tự động nhận diện nó
sai đơn chưa
bé bé thì có thể là do
cái cái này đợi đợi đợi tôi một tí đang
dùng h đang dùng chuột
Laptop này Cái volume nó cứ tự động
chỉnh bé lại à không không volume này
khác quên quên qu đây volume
alo alo đù to hơn chưa
ạ Alo Ui đỏ này cho to lắm
thằng cái thằng ồn rẻ
đây chỉnh lại cho độ nhạy bởi vì tôi
đang mở quạt tản nhiệt nữa nên nó sẽ
chưa Tôi đang mở quả tàn nhiệt mà đỡ
chưa
thì dùng Google meet nên thành ra là
kiểu khi mà mic nó to quá nó tự động
hình như chỉnh lại hình như thế hình như
thế chắc là nó bắt trước của thằng m à
Hôm trước tôi bị cái lỗi đấy trên m kiểu
cứ dùng bất kỳ cái gì gọi thì mic to quá
nó tự động kiểu chỉnh lại cân đối lại
này n bị thế
Tôi vừa chỉ lại mic to hơn tự nhiên năm
sao có người nghe tốt rồi một hai người
nghe cũng được Quan trọng gì tâm mình
tâm sự ai cảm thấy có nh câu cần nghe
nghe mà đúng không ạ à Thôi tôi tâm sự
nốt cái này đó
là thì tôi tôi kể mấy ông vụ câu chuyện
hài đấy ở trên J2 chưa nhở đó là vì tôi
cảm thấy tôi gần giống thế rồi đó là
kiểu Hồi đấy trên J2 community J Chu chứ
chuẩn là j Chu J Chu community vi team
community thì
j j team Đúng rồi J team Z team
community Hồi đấy có một ông Ông ấy đang
bài hỏi đó là à Em muốn thử tính năng tố
cáo của Facebook nên em tạo nick clon ra
xu em dùng nick clon để tố cáo nick
chính x bay luôn nick chính Bây giờ làm
thế nào lấy lại được hạ mọi người kiểu
thế bài đang đấy lâu phết rồi từ hồi
2017 ch 7 năm rồi cái nick clon hô đấy
ch B giờ viên hh đích chính rồi
đấy Hồi đấy tôi cười x Bọn tôi thì thần
cười kiểu bảo Tại sao không muốn thử
tính năng tố cáo đấy Tại sao không dùng
nick chính tố cáo nick clon dùng nick
clon đ tố cáo nick chính đấy Kiểu thế
đấy
thì gần đây tôi tôi kể mấy ông Việ tôi
bị khóa Facebook chư nhở Bởi vì tôi thử
chạy tool kiểu kiểm tra tương tác Những
ai tương tác mình nhiều nhất rồi mình là
tin ai nhiều nhất đấy bằng nick chính
của tôi xong rồi bây giờ Facebook đang
khóa nghi ngờ có dấu hiệu kiểu hành động
bất Hường n thứ thứ không biết bao giờ
được gỡ thì lúc đấy tôi nghĩ kiểu biết
th đáng ẽ mình phải nên dùng nick clon
test luôn demo thẳng trên nick chính cho
sinh viên xem thô bây giờ bị bay
nick đúng rồi mấy ông nên luôn có nick
clon đề phòng và luôn dùng nick đấy demo
chứ không
phải có người bây giờ thì đang bảo tôi
thôi Dùng luôn nick clon kia nhanh không
biết là nick chính thế nào và động chí
là còn đượcc nó nên phụ thuộc nick chính
quá Nhưng mà đại khái Tôi muốn lấy lại
nick bởi vì nó trên đấy nó gắn nhiều kỷ
niệm thôi Và nó có như liên hệ và thực
ra mọi người cũng biết tôi qua nick đấy
nữa nên tôi muốn lấy ạ đương nhiên là
vẫn Khôi Nếu giả sử Giả sử bằng cách
thân kiaa
đó thì nick không lấy lại được thì chắc
là mình cũng phải cân nhắc dùng nick
clon lên Nhưng mà thực ra nick clon tôi
trường hợp nào có người dùng nick clon
là để mà Một nhân cách khác con nick
clon là kiểu để đăng kiểu thấy nhân cách
khác ngườ đăng các thứ thứ con người
khác luôn nick clon tôi đúng nghĩa là nó
nên là một nick clon tức
cả nó nên ẩn thân hoàn toàn gần như là
tôi rất hạn chế cho người khác biết nick
clon của tôi cơ thể nên là thành ng Tôi
không muốn cái nick đấy nó sẽ bên lên
nick chính clon là nên là clon tôi còn
chẳng đăng gì lên đây có để muốn nó là
một nick ẩn mà đúng không Nghĩa là ừ chỉ
gần như là nick đấy gần như là hồi trước
là dùng để ngồi kiểm tra xem có thực sự
có ông nào đó chặn mình hay là chến giản
ông ấy khóa Facebook đ một cái Điển hình
nick clon mà chắc chắn là không ai chặn
cái nick clon đấy rồi đấy đ th dùng nick
đấy để ngồi kiểm vào trang cá nhân người
khác ngồi kiểm tra đấy là một cái đấy
cck
ẩ Cho dù rõ ràng Gần đây tôi phải dùng
Chính cái nick đấy để đi inbox người
khác hơi
buồn về sao tô lại chặn mấy người đấy nó
biến thành nick ẩn lại
bị Tại sao ông lại bị trường Block được
nhỉ nhắc mà nhớ Hồi trước tôi cũng bị
từng bị một cái page fan page à
confection của trường chặm nhưng mà Bởi
vì tôi bị kiểu nói chung là cái đứa
admin của p ấy hơi r
xích nó ghét tôi xong rồi nó chặn tôi
bằng cái p thế nhưng xong rồi nó đăng
conversion nó xấu tôi nhưng mà đại khái
ông làm gì để bị thế vậy Ủa
niclon để mà làm một cái hành động gì đó
khác ví dụ là kiểua bán một cái gì đó
hay là đấy đi hỏi ngu hoặc là thậm chí
là tôi có quen ông anh ông ấy chưa dùng
nick clon để đi tạo gy các thứ thứ buồn
cười anh ấy toàn kiểu Đăng hoặc là bình
luận gì đó gây gua không đến nỗi là kiểu
dạng là phân biệt vùng miền hay cái gì
gì đó đâu nhưng mà nghĩa là kiểu kích
Chử nhau ấy Thậm chí anh đem đi Nick ấy
đi chửi nhau mà xong rồi anh ấy chơi cái
trò rất là độc ác đấy Kiểu ra anh kích
kế xong xong anh ấy tắt xử thông báo của
anh đi ngủ xong anh bảo làm thế ngủ cho
ngon Đúng kiểu người đầu B thành
thơi Anh cứ đi Kích Xong rồi anh ấ Chửi
luôn cả hai bên cơ ví dụ Giả sử đang có
tranh luận x nổ đúng không anh ấy vào
anh ấy chửi luôn cả hai bên thử thứ xu
anh ấy tắt Thúc bảo anh đi ngủ định
may ông chị bị bêu tên cho toàn
trường inbox riêng thôi có những cái tế
nhị chúng ta Nếu mà muốn nói ra thì
inbox riêng nó là khái niệm gọi là như
nào nhỉ khái niệm hồi trước tôi có nghe
cái câu Cứ Cho Là Mình Cứ cho là mình
hơi như nào đấy Thực ra nó không hay lắm
tôi không thể khuyên mấy ông như này vì
đôi khi là mình nên không nên nói có
những điều mình không nên nói ra không
mà giả sử Nếu thực sự ông muốn nói ấ thì
không bao giờ nên nói xấu sau lưng đúng
không nên nói thằng trước mặt nó là và
nói với tính cách xây dựng ấy chứ không
phải nói với kiểu ném đá nên là Nên là
gọi nhờ Nếu có thể thì nên nói riêng cho
nhau chứ không phải nói công khai tất cả
mọi người cũng thấy người ta sẽ bị tự ái
người ta bị cái cái tôi vân vân người ta
sẽ phản pháo người ta sẽ hành động nó
kiểu phản ứng lại ấy không tốt đấy ví dụ
Ông thầy có vấn đề thì ông cần GP ý thì
ông sẽ nói riêng một cách tế nhị nhất
đấy và nên nói thẳng với người ta không
nên nói thông qua bất kỳ cái gì cả Đấy
là tốt nhất đấy thế thôi còn nếu mà ông
không dám nói thẳng trước mặt như thì
ông không nên nói xấu so lưng
đấy chưa tôi đọp được cái
đấy đấy Hồi trước tôi đọc nhưng mà tôi
áp dụng không phải trệt đề lắm nhiều cái
đúng rồi tôi vẫn dùng form Danh thật gọi
như nào bởi vì cái lần gần nhất tôi dùng
form MN danh bởi vì nói thả cho mặt nó
cũng không nghe tôi dùng luôn không phải
ẩn danh
với không phải ẩn danh với nó mà gọi nhở
tôi nói tôi điền tên tôi trong đấy nhưng
mà form này đúng tên là ẩ form ẩn danh
cho tôi vẫn điền tên tôi đây đóng góp ý
xuất kết bạn những bạn ở nick chính liệu
những bạn bè nick chính có hiện đề
xuất thường ấy gọi như là tôi từng bị
một người
chặn sau đó tôi dùng nick clon tôi vẫn
thấy người đấy chặn tôi biết được người
đấy chặn bởi người đấy không khóa face
mở ẩn danh lên thấy vẫn vào được face
bạn
đấy thì hóa ra Facebook nó sẽ xác định
theo
chắc Thế f lắ đấy thì
thì Facebook nó sẽ theo địa chỉ IP chẳng
hạn đấy Nên là khi mà chặn một người bây
giờ nó thường ha gợi ý xem là bạn có
muốn chặn tất cả những cái nick có thể
của người đấy tạo ra không
đấy thành ra đề xuất thì cũng có thể một
phần là do địa chỉ IP hay vân vân nữa
thứ hai
là là do chính danh bạ của các bạn thôi
các bạn thường hay cho phép Facebook
truy cập danh bạ nên là sẽ thường theo
danh bạ Thằng Tít cũng thế mà thằng
tiktok Ui nó là một cái đề xuất kiểu tôi
thấy là đề xuất không những Facebook nhá
Nó đề xuất cả B insta cơ có theo dõi
người insta bây giờ nó cũng gợi ý ở trên
Facebook ạ à trên tiktok đấy tôi cảm
thấy thằng tiktok nó mới thằng kiểu ăn
dày nhất nó gợi ý Kiểu vãi chưởng không
biết nó lấy toàn bộ thông tin đấy từ đâu
K thế th rõ ràng là mình chỉ kết nối
Facebook đến thôi nghĩa là CN mắm là nó
chỉ đọc được danh sách bạn bè Facebook
đây nó để xuất được những cái
kiểu không biết được nó đã đọc được
những thông tin gì
đâu vì bây giờ mọi người C Đăng email
lên Facebook lắm
dùng nick clon đăng bài bình luận về sở
thích vì không muốn người thân biết về
sở thích Ừ không không quan tâm để đen
tối hay không Nói chung là đúng là mình
không thích thì mình có thể dùng nick
clon làm những việc thì tôi bảo đấy Nó
là một nhân cách một con người khác của
mình nên tôi không dùng nick clon để làm
việc đấy thế nên thành ra hồi trước cũng
có người ném đá tôi rồi kìa À không phải
người ném đá nó nó nhở khuyên tôi rồi
kìa Tại sao em thể nói m cái gọi là
không phải có thể nói mà đại sao em
không dùng nick clon để làm những cái
điều đấy đấy ấy thì tôi bảo tôi không
muốn giả tạo Tôi muốn sống thật nên
thành ra là kể cả cho dù tôi ngu tôi kèm
vân vân tôi vẫn muốn dùng Chính nick
chính của mình để làm những điều đấy để
tôi thả bị chửi còn hơn là dùng nick
clon xong rồi Kiểu trông nó cũng chẳng
uy tín nữa tự nhiên ông dùng nick clon
để ông nói một cái gì đó để ông hỏi một
cái gì đó chẳng hạn trong chẳng uy tín K
chẳng ai muốn trả lời chẳng ai muốn
trách luận với cái thằng đấy với cái
thằng nick clon đấy cả đấy dùng hẳn nick
chính tôi bởi vì gọi nh tôi theo con
điểm là cái gì mà tôi không không thích
người khác làm tôi sẽ không làm thế
người khác tôi từng rất là khó chịu với
mấy cái ông kiểu gây gua hay
là hay là kiểu đi bình luận kiểu kích
kích các thứ thứ bằng nick clon ấy hoặc
m cái fanpage kiểu kiểu mới tạo ấy mình
không hiểu cái đấy đúng không
đấy Kiểu mấy thằng kiểu nó kiểu núp núp
sau lưng mấy kiểu thấy nó nói tôi đã rớt
Ghét mấy thằng đấy rồi nên là thành ra
tôi sẽ không mờ muốn trở thành kiểu
thằng kiểu cũng tương tự như thế mình
tạo một cái fanpage hoặc là một cái clon
nào đó Phả đi kích kích các thứ th không
dùng Hoàn đích
f thì tốt Nó mắt mà Mấy ông cũng nên
dùng cái này tốt mắt
tốt mắt chứ sao Bây giờ đi ngủ rồi mà
thằng Windows thường hình như nó chỉ có
kiểu
hai nó không nó không phân ra nhiều cấp
ấy nó chỉ c hai cấp
thôi nó cái é lắc é
có ảnh hưởng đến màn hình các bạn không
chưa hiểu sao mấy cái extension làm sao
thể ghé được uid theo danh séch bạn bé
lắm
biết api của Facebook là có hỗ trợ không
chắc là có
không
ạ Hôm qua chính ông em ở đây vừa ngồi
chê chê tôi kiểu phát tiếng Anh
nhớ gọi là anh bị kiểu nói nhầm thôi
Không không cái cái đấy là lỗi cơ bản
quá không chuyện là mình thể phát âm sai
kiu đấy được chúng ta không có Long Em
phiên ản hai ở đây nhưng mà đại khái
thì đầu tiên thì phải hỏi là tôi có
thích tiếng Anh không mình có trả lời có
tôi nghe nhạc và tiếp xúc nền văn hóa
kiểu ô Mỹ các thử từ khá sớm từ bé anh
là t không ngại Việc học tiếng Anh
à Kiểu còn thích hả Thi nghĩa chỉ là
kiểu kiểu kể cả cho dù không học trên
trường thì tôi hồi đây tôi tôi vẫn đủ
nghe để hiểu Nói chung là đại khái cái
kiến thức trên trường
nó kiến thức trên trường họ được học các
thứ thứ thì À nó chắc là chiếm chứ đến
10 ph kiến thức của tôi hiện tại về về
tiếng Anh vì rõ ràng là tôi à chủ yếu
vẫn là nghe học nghe thậm chí là nói
luôn các thứ tôi vẫn nói chuyện kiểu vẫn
vẫn ngồi à Nói chuyện với đối tác bằng
nước ngoài bằng tiếng Anh các thứ thôi
thì tôi cảm thấy là là nên thế nghĩa
mình thích cái gì đó mình kiểu đấy mấy
ông để ý bây giờ giao diện toàn bộ tội
tiếng Anh này để làm quen hết toàn bộ
tiếng Anh chứ đấy Không vấn đề gì
tiếng Anh nó là kiểu kiểu như
em tiếng chị tiếng Phú
Anh thì có nhiều cái dịch ra tiếng Việt
nó kiểu có bị thô V hay các thứ mình đọc
còn khó hiểu mà mình để tiếng Anh thì nó
còn đá nghĩa hơn tí nhưng mà tôi không
thể nói mà nói thế là kiểu dạng là làm
tự tôn tôi có Điền hình nhá nhắc n Long
tự tôn n mình nhớ kiểu tôi đ làm gần đây
làm việc với kiểu đối tác ở bên Trung
Tôi đã kể mấy ông về cái Long tự tôn của
bên chung chưa Nó là kiểu không biết là
mấy ông có quen người chung ở đây hay
thậm chí có người chung ở đây đang nghe
không Tôi biết khẳng định được là bên
trung tự tôn cao phết theo kiểu là
à nếu nếu mà nó gần như là nếu mà nói
chuyện với nó nó sẽ rất Thiên hướng là
hướng mình sang nói bằng tiếng của nó
thậm chí và sang bên Trung là còn nhiều
kể cả nói biết tiếng Anh nó vẫn sẽ nó
thậm chí có nhiều cái hài châm biến mấy
video hài châm biến về bộ đấy mà nĩa kể
cả nó biết tiếng Anh nó vẫn kiểu cố
hướng kiểu ta nói luôn là tao không biết
tiếng Anh mày nói tiếng chung tao hiểu
vậ các thờ th nó bị cười thế nghĩa là nó
cần Như là nó cứ hướng hướng mình sang
cái ngôn ngữ mẹ đẻ của nó các thứ thế
thậm chí nó đăng lên rất nhiều cái trang
kể cả trang quốc tế ở nó ví dụ Điền hình
trang gí hấ gì gì đó nó vẫn để tiếng của
nó chứ không phải để tiếng Anh kể tao
không cần mày đọc mày hiểu m à Mày muốn
hiểu thì mày phải học ngôn ngữ của tao
mày phải tự tìm cách mà dịch Tao không
dịch của mày tao không dùng ngôn ngữ nữ
của mày tao không theo sân chơi của mày
tao theo phong cách của tao đấy kê
Thế xem nhìn màn hình lạ
nhỉ Đây cũng là một điểm nhấn đấy
đấy
thì nói chuyện với mấy ông đối tác kiểu
thấy khó chịu cực hôm trước nói chuyện
bằng tiếng ảnh nó đã xem ạ xong rồi tôi
phải nhờ cái chị dịch ra tiếng Trung nó
mới kiểu bắt đầu ngồi trả lời đấy Xong
rồi Kiểu Wow tôi còn biết được mấy cái
quả g h kiểu Đăng g h ở nó nhá Đấy xong
rồi có vài ông hỗ trợ tạo per kiểu
tạo kiểu phiên bản tiếng Anh ấ me phiên
bản tiếng Anh nó không
ryn có
cực 54 mà Trinh vênh của anh Anh nghĩ là
bây giờ ai cũng Chinh vênh thôi em ạ đến
cả ra ngoài ra ngoài đời cũng Chinh vênh
mỗi đội tuổi nó có cái
theo anh ấ thì nói chung là bây giờ anh
Kiểu nhìn theo góp độ lạc quan nhiều hơn
rồi đó là mình còn nghĩ được mình còn
làm được thì mình cứ làm Mình cứ vui vì
mình được nghĩ còn hơn là mình cảm thấy
mình không có cách nào kể bế tắc lắm rồi
không thể làm được gì cả không thể nghĩ
được gì không thể giải quyết được cái gì
lúc đấy mới đáng lo em ạ Còn bây giờ ừ
thì nó có thể làm được nhưng nó khó thì
mình nghĩ hãy nghĩ kiểu là quan nó lại
khó với mình thì cũng khó với thằng kia
thế thôi chúng ta cũng khó thì xem thằng
nào cháy cối hơn thì chẳng n ăn đấy Kiểu
thế Thằng nào kiểu có trò may mắn hơn
Vân Vân rất nhiều tố hơn chẳng ng ăn đấy
cuộc sống nó cũng bây giờ cũng cạnh
tranh rồi mà đúng không làm sao xong
phẳng mãi được làm sao kiểu làm sao mà
kiểu tất cả mọi người cùng học cùng lớp
cùng Mình Cùng chyên ngành cùng mình đều
ra đều kiếm việc làm ngon được sẽ có ông
ngon có ông không đúng không ạ Đấy thì
ông nào mà may mắn ông nào rất nhiều ý
tố Nhưng mà quan trọng ông là trụ được
thì thằng ấy thắng thế thôi chứ còn nghĩ
việc à cứ nghĩ nhiều về việc
là nó khó nó vân vân vân thì nó chẳng
giải quyết vấn đề gì cả Mình phải nghĩ
cái gì ạ Mình chỉ nghĩ những cái thứ
mình có thể giải quyết được những cái
thứ mình kiểm soát được những cái gì
mình không kiểm soát được thì đừng có
nghĩ
đúng
việc không ạ Ông thử lên hỏi len Xem kết
bạn nhiều bạn HR mà Tại vì mấy bạn xinh
xinh ấ thì mấy bạn đấy cũng chắc chắn là
mấy bạn cũng kết bạn nhiều ô khác s Tự
đăng
CV
nói chung là mấy ông phải tìm thử mọi
cách đi đúng không có vấn đề gì đó có
vấn đề đúng không mình thửng mọi cách có
thể sáng tạo lên đừng có ngại Đừng có
ngại gì nữa dồ về mấy sau mấy ông nhận
ra là kiểu càng ngại mấy ông càng chẳng
làm được cái gì cả mấy ông đừng có ngại
database lạ lại như cassandra mongo
mongo có đấy new thì tôi không biết
cassandra
thì tôi chưa gặp bao giờ nhưng mongo có
nhiều
ngộp quá không nên chuyển ngành qua công
Em tin không ạ Anh thấy ngày nào cũng
ngộp
Mà anh thấy nếu mà em đang là học giờ đy
nhiên nó cũng có cái khó riêng anh không
biết được thực sự hoàn cảnh em đang cảm
thấy như thế nào Nhưng
mà đừng vì khó mà bỏ cuộc vì ng cái gì
nó cũng sẽ khó em thà em có một cái lý
do gì đó khác kiểu thậm chí là kiểu em
đang có chống lưng ở cái lĩnh vực này
đấy em cảm thấy lĩnh vực kia em tươi
sáng hơn vì có chống lưng vân vân Em
sang đấy em em hồi trước em học tốt cái
kia em cảm thấy em sang đây được chứ bây
giờ bảo là em nhảy sang cái mới cái đấy
mới toanh Thì cái nào đối với em cũng
thành khó thôi đúng không nên là thôi
đừng có vì khó quá bỏ em ạ chẳng có
ngành nào bây giờ dễ đâu cái dễ thì
không thấy lênn mình đúng không Đừng
đừng nghĩ việc dễ
nữa anh thể thế nào về chương trình
Viettel Digital Talent anh không biết em
ạ Không biết không chia sẻ
được anh ơi yên tập xài UB
u
ông học lại thì chắc chắn là tôi không
dùng cái hệ điều hành này nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ ông phía sa hành tạ rồi u bu tu u
bu
tu uun xong
UB xem nào
uun
Tu Đây
ẹ Tôi nghĩ là ông cứ thử đi có sao đâu
thử xong rồi tự mình cảm nhận
có
có đừng đừng đừng nghe đánh giá của bất
kỳ ai cả cái hệ đềa hành mấy cái đấy đề
n là nhau mà ông cứ thử trải nghiệm đi
Ví dụ điển hình ông em kia chẳng hạn ông
Duy ấ ông ấy dùng cái liner UBU thì ông
ấy khen anh tôi tôi dùng tôi từng dùng
qua tôi vẫn thích dùng cái Windows hơn
chẳng hạn kệ nó nói gì kệ chứ Mình phải
quan điểm riêng mình chứ nghe mấy người
khác nói làm
gì mình có phải giống nó đâu đúng không
Tính cách mình có giống nó đâu Anh không
quan tâm đấy Em dùng cái gì việc với em
Anh dùng cái gì về anh đúng không Mỗi
người có một cái đầu tiên là mình phải
đầu tiên mình phải biết được lý do lý do
mình thích cái này ví dụ Giả sử Tôi dùng
thích cái Windows này vì có game vì cài
đm các thứ hòa chẻ gi mình quen rồi mình
quen phim tắt của bên này rồi Vân Vân
mình cảm thấy thoải mái được Mà hệ điều
hành sinh ra để thoải mái người dùng mà
chứ không phải để thoải mái cho cái
thằng thằng khác
đâu phải không phải là kiểu hệ đ hành
sinh ra vì bọn nó được up nhiều nó lên
cao đâu cái đấy đâu quan trọng gì không
nhỉ đúng
không
nay chỉ tâm sự chứ không Cốt nữa hả anh
đúng n chuột Tôi còn đang ở một phương
xa n cho cả thực ra gần đây bị rất nhiều
bận rộn đau đầu thật ắ rồi nhỉ quên quên
nhắc mấy không Thứ năm tôi lại phải xin
nghỉ tiếp Vì vì đấy
Ờ tối mai liên hoan này tối ngày kia lại
liên hoan này
Đấy chắc
là không biết bao giờ mới động code nữa
Tôi hy vọng Chắc sang sang tuần sẽ cố
động lại code
vậy Anh so sánh S với tr đi ạ một trong
những điểm tôi ghét nhất ấ đó là mang
tiếng là nó có cái kiểu kêu đồng bộ đồng
bộ từ trình duyệt này sang trình duyệt
kiểu từ chome sang cái này tô thấy là
vẫn còn thiếu kiểu về lịch sử web x ngồi
thậm chí là cả pqu này không biết là do
tôi kiểu lưu nhiều quá hay ra vân vân vẻ
là chưa đồng bộ được hết
còn đâu về tiện ích thì có vẻ có rồi này
tốc độ thì tôi thấy cũng không biết được
cảm giác cảm giác sử dụng của tôi ấy thì
tôi thấy không bằng chom Ờ đấy cảm giác
thôi Cảm giác thôi không biết So sánh cụ
thể hơn kỹ về cái phần gì
Ờ
mật khẩu của thằng của thằng Google mà
có gì thậm chí là nó đề xuất ở trên
Android nữa còn gì nhỉ
cái setting nó có nhiều tùy biến hơn
thằng chom hoặc là chắc là do tôi chưa
máu kỹ về thằng
chom C gì
nhỉ Cứ tạm thời Thế đã tôi kh Tôi nghĩ
thêm tôi sẽ trời
Tôi đang định dùng những cái thằng thuần
Thực ra là tôi vẫn cứ cho là hơi cổ hù
tí tôi vẫn kiểu thích hàng Microsoft với
thằng Google nói chung là tôi muốn kiểu
hệ sinh thái của mấy thằng đấy vân vân
chứ không phải là tôi không phải là
người mà cứ kiểu
cứ C kiểu
à mỗi thằng Đương nhiên là mỗi thằng nó
sẽ mạnh ở một cái khía cạnh ở nó ví dụ
là kiểu cho là thằng PR hay gì gì đó thì
nó mạnh về cái Trinh duyệt hơn tất cả
các thằng khác Giả sử thế đúng không
Nhưng mà tôi kiểu vẫn chấp nhận dùng cái
thằng thứ hai thứ ba miễn là nó cùng
trong hệ sinh thái n đỡ phải nghĩ hơi bị
kiểu như thế Tôi không h mò mấy cái kia
lắm Nhưng mà nói thế nhưng mà tôi vẫn
ghét vs code nhá vs code của Microsoft
nhưng vẫn ghét đang dùng nhưng vẫn
Google à Ý em là cái Bin Đúng không Bin
thì chuyên về tài liệu hơn
Ờ nhưng mà nhưng mà tìm kiếm những cái
khác thì anh thấy không thể Mấy lần anh
phải chuyển qua Google anh tìm kiếm đấy
không
bằng tì sub btic đâu rồi à tôi còn mua
bản quyền Sach đấy nhưng mà tội ở
subtech thì đúng là đều hơn V code thật
không thể thể phủ nhận điều đấy nhưng mà
Đúng là nhiều lúc gọn nhẹ Tôi sẽ mở s
Tech lên để làm việc kiểu đúng nghĩa là
nhọn gọn nhẹ không cần phải nghĩ gì cả ấ
không cần code gì trong đấy ho chế đơn
giản để độc lập với code của mình hiện
tại t dùng
á n vim á n vim Hình như là kiểu
nó thiên hướng về kiểu dùng câu lệnh
nhiều đúng
không anh ơi năm nay em lên đại học
nhưng vì các năm trước mày chơi nên hiện
tại mới nhận ra Việc học quan trọng nào
mà em rất thích muốn học lờ trình mà
không thi được lý hóa sinh vì mất gốc
anh
nhưng mà Thực ra nếu thực sự em muốn học
thì lời khuyên là để tránh bị bị tụt hợ
với các bạn thì em thể kiểu bây giờ em
thể học à cao đẳng xong về sau liên
thông nếu mà em thực sự muốn học để học
nhưng mà Cao Đẳng nó không dạy đủ kiến
thức bằng đại học cũng như là việc lúc
mà học liên thông nó cũng không dạy đủ
kiến thức Còn nếu mà em muốn học vì đây
đang nói học về kiểu bằng cấp nhá và một
lý thuyết nhá Còn nếu mà em thực sự muốn
học học một ngày nào đó thì để để để
thực hành thôi thì em có thể học các đả
nghề kiểu các thứ thứ thì đấy khóa có
thể ngắn hạn hơn cũng như là nó thực tế
hơn về nó thực hành nhưng mà em phải xác
định xem là mình phù hợp với cái việc
học lý thuyết hay học thực hành nữa ví
dụ anh anh cảm thấy anh phù hợp học lý
th học thực hành hơn nên là anh cảm thấy
hồi thấy anh Trượt đại học để mà
vào nghề nó cũng là một cái gì đó gọi là
may mắn với mình nhưng không hoàn toàn
phù hợp với tất cả mọi người bởi vì
chuẩn là mình phải có tư duy tương đối
và mình vẫn phải khả năng tự học vân vân
và bây giờ anh vẫn có phải học thêm lại
lý thuyết các thứ các thứ chứ nếu mà chỉ
thực hành thôi tự nhiên chưa đủ đúng
không chung là mình sẽ
phải có một cái độ kỳ luật nhất định
thì tôi dùng pp Storm à Tôi dùng pp stor
mở trên công ty Nói chung là dùng máy để
code chuẩn thì đang dùng của Je
Brain s có cái đọc pdf xịn hơn có read
out la đọc được tiếng Việt và file pdf
Ok nhưng mà tôi chưa mở file BF lại
nhiều lắm không để không quan tâm m lắm
ram 16
GB chạy vs code V code Tại sao ram 16 GB
chắc không đủ nhờ ông ông cài cái gì
đấy à đây bạn nữ à đúng
không cái gì vậy sao tận 16 GB vậy 16 GB
không đủ à Cái này nó nhẹ nhẹ ngang bằng
cái subtech chứ mấy cài thêm một vài cái
nữa nặng hơn tí lập trình không cần giỏi
Toán đúng rồi nhưng mà học các bạn phải
hiểu Hồi trước học mộ cái môn tự nhiên
là có thể dàn cái tư duy logic hay vân
vân Nếu giả sử là mấy mấy ông mà không
có kiểu tư duy Mấy ông không logic có
lắm
thì thì cũng phải cân nhắc ngại bởi vì
rõ ràng học lập trình cần có một cái độ
logic nhất định chứ tôi ngồi nói chuyện
với mấy ông ở trên công ty cũng là một
Điền hình kiểu có những ông đồng nghiệp
mà tôi luôn phải tự hỏi m cái tư duy
kiểu như Tại sao là lập trình viên được
đấy là một cái đểa TH
kiểu tư duy lệch sai lệch kinh khủng
kiểu nó có nói những câu ngốc nghích
kiểu hiển nhiên ấy kiểu thế nên tôi cảm
thấy là kiểu thứ nhất là ngạc nhiên khi
nó làm đ trí viên này Thứ hai là ngạc
nhiên khi công ty có thể tuyển nó này
Vân Vân vâ đôi khi n biến thành gánh
nặng đấy gánh nặng người khác chứ không
biết là ông ấy có là gánh nặng chính bản
thân ông ấy không họ ông cảm nhận được
không nhưng mà chắc chắn là nó gánh nặng
đó đấy Nên nói chung mấy ông phải cân
nhắc Nếu mà m ông không cảm thấy là
logic của mấy ông nó hơi bay bổng quá nó
hơ không không lý trí lắm
confic r rồi đẩy anh git Ừ cái này anh
khó trả lời quá em có vấn đề gì đó cụ
thể thì em hỏi trên server discord để
các bạn hỗ trợ nhá chứ anh không dành về
đây lắm anh nghĩ có như bạn trong này
biết mấy cái đấy đấy nên học Go
không
th em thích thì có thể học thôi không
phải mỗi nước ngoài đâu ở Việt Nam mình
dùng nhiều lắm đặc biệt là thậm chí là
chuyển từ lel P để mà chuyển cóg Lang ấy
m cứ học đi càng tốt
mềm quản lý bán hàng thử thử thì nên
chọn p bất kỳ ngôn ngữ nào anh thấy
trong đấy đều có thể làm được hết em ạ n
em cứ thấy cái nào mà em đang cảm thể
quen thuộc em làm
hả
Sao anh nói thấy giật mình ghê Anh thử
ví dụ vài câu
xem vài câu á Câ như nào
nhỉ ví dụ hôm trước tôi chửi cái ông
đồng nghiệp ví dụ Kiểu cái test nó phê
rồi Nó ngồi rerun lại mấy lần
liền hiy vọng cái test nó pass mà rõ
ràng là cái đấy sai về logic với code
ông rerun cả đời ngồi kiểu reset máy đi
cài lại vân vân vân thì nó vẫn sẽ thôi
vì rõ ràng sai về tư duy sai về trong
hẳn trong code đấy đấy một cái Điền hình
thôi nghĩa là nó không hiểu được code nó
đang chạy như th nào ấy nghĩ rằng Ừ máy
có vấn đề à Hay kích củng cái gì gì đó
ấy phải chạy lại ấ đấy thấy một
cái hoa Chỉ đơn
giản đôi khi rerun lại chạy được Đúng
tôi không phủ nhận việc run nó chạy được
nhưng mà tôi đọc cái đoạn code đấy rồi
và logic đấy nó kiể run thế nào nó giống
kiểu ông ngồi kiểm tra 1 cộ 1 bằng 3 ấy
thì ông ngồi run thế nào đợi đ Khi nào
để nó thành Chu lúc đấy Có lúc mà nó
pass Đấy mới gọi là có vấn đề ông hiểu
không
đấy Hồi trước kiểu kiểu nó bị sai lỗi cơ
đẳng về gọi là sơ đẳng về về lập trình
cơ nhớ hình như là nó kiểu nó bị nhầm về
cái all ấ không biết m không biết khái
niệm aare ở
thức ra tôi nghĩ là có vai ông Ly bị
dính rồi n là tôi
này dụ We cái gì gì đó s có o ở đây đúng
không như này đúng không biết K nà ví dụ
là 1 bằng 1 à đâu 1 bằ 2 o 1 bằ 1 kiểu
như này đúng không kiểu như này đúng
không hôm đấy tôi phải ngồi giải thích
lại nó O cái O là một trong hai cái đều
được không quan tâm đến cái vế này đấy
tôi ci ngồi giải thích lại nó về cái
khái niệm o này cơ thức ra hình như là
hôm đấy nó phức tạp hơn một tí thì phải
đấy như này
đây cứ ch 1 bằng 2 tiếp đi Đấy cái O này
này o này này đúng không Nó là o cho tất
cả những cái trên rồi theo tôi nhớ là
như thế đấy anh anh Tuấn anh
lắm Nếu thế Chứng tỏ là ông không theo
dõi kênh của anh Tuấn
là là kiểu toàn bộ cái trước đúng hay
sai không quan trọng cái O nó sẽ chỉ cần
miễn là cái này đúng là coi như toàn bộ
cái trước vứt đi đúng không hôm đấy tôi
phải ngồi giải thích cái này cho
ngồi giải thích lại mấy
cái kiểu Nguyên lì cơ bản của lập trình
thế này đâu Kiểu cái này kiểu học lập
trình mới không phải biết mà đúng không
en với o c thử đúng
kiến thức hiển nhiên này có phải là sinh
viên đại học đâu thưa bạn đây là người
đi làm
rồi Đây là người đi làm rồi kinh nghiệm
2 năm bằng thực C đang được đánh cây B
bằng tôi tức là ngang bằng xio
để đi interm thì em học Note js hay Java
thì tỉ lệ cao
hơn anh thấy là em thử đọc qua nó xem
cái nào phù hợp phù hợp hơn sa rồi Em
học em học chuyên sâu được cái nào thì
tỉ lệ cái đấy đi làm cao hơn thôi chứ
đừng phụ thuộc về việc ngôn ngữ nào đang
hot vì ngôn ngữ đang hot mà em không làm
được thì nó bằng không mà đúng
không vô kinh VP hỏi ơ sao đánh đồng thế
sao Coi kênh của tôi là kênh pp rồi kênh
của tôi là kênh tâm sự tu tuổi chững
chập chững mà đúng không Chứ có phải
kênh kênh pp
ngoặc vào thì nó dễ hiểu hơn nhưng mà
bản chất bản chất ở đây không quan trọng
việc đóng mở ngoặc gì cả bản chất là
phải hiểu quá Cái này chứ B có phải đi
đóng mở ngoặc cho nó dễ
Bữa nào anh mở lớp trả Phi đi ạ học dễ
Phi nhiều khi không tiếc nên đâm ra lời
học ấy ạ Cái này Thực ra là tôi hồi
trước đ từng nói mấy ông rồi đó là quan
điểm
là nếu mà Mấy ông đang học trên ngành ấy
mấy ông chưa ra ngoài đời đủ va chạm
nhiều để bị để bị
à để bị tát Hẳng gáo nước vào mặt vân
vân vân ấy giống như tôi đã từng kiểu bị
bị kêu là về học lại equ đi Chẳng hạn
đấy đấy thì mấy ông sẽ không trân trọng
mấy ông sẽ kiểu học cũng được không học
cũng được Còn khi mà Mấy ông bị kiểu đấy
Hoa đậm chế thất nghiệp v Vân Vân Vân
khi mà kiểu lúc đấy thì một đồng tiền nó
cũng quý đúng không Đấy các thử thì mấy
ông sẽ cảm thấy là kiểu những cái những
cái miễn phí mà nó có thể đem lại được
chất lượng các thử thứ giá trị như nào
Đúng không Nó là giá trị cái này tôi bảo
rồi cái kênh Tôi đang bị TH hướng nó là
không phải là cho người đúng trên
ngành thường là những người mà
à trái ngành chuyển sang muốn thử cái
ngành mới hoặc là những bạn Nói chung là
kiểu lầm đường cứ cho lầm đường lạc lối
hay vân vân kiểu đang mù mờ Đang kiểu
không biết bộ bám víu ở đâu các thử các
thứ thì thử học qua thấy phù hợp thì
theo V không mất gì
cả chính xác là không Phả dùng từ không
mất gì cả như tôi từng nói đó là các bạn
có mất đấy các bạn mất một cái rất lớn
đó mất thời
gian các bạn mất phải bỏ thời gian ra
chứ đúng không cái đấy tôi thấy mới là
quý nhất thì
thì thì lúc đấy các bạn sẽ thấy trân
trọng thôi chứ còn còn nếu mà tôi Tôi
cảm thấy đồng tiền nó mới là một cái thứ
hôm trước tôi nói chuyện với sinh viên
tôi mọi người mọi người thường hay nghĩ
đặn nặng về vấn đề tiền bạc cho dù Thực
ra tôi cảm thấy tiền lại là một thứ kiếm
dễ nhất tôi nói Thấy không phải vì tôi
giàu hay khá giả gì cả Tôi không không
không giàu hay khá giả nhưng mà tôi đang
nói là đúng là đồng tiền mấy thứ kiếm dễ
nhất bây giờ ai cũng có thể kiếm tiền
hôm qua ít ít hay nhiều thôi mà đúng
không ạ Đấy ít hay nhiều thôi Giờ G ai
chẳng kiếm được tiền cái đấy là thứ dễ
kiếm và cũng và nó lại là nên là một thứ
dễ cho đi nhất đấy còn những cái khác
mới gọi là khó thời gian là một cái quý
này công sức mọi thứ mình là một cái quý
này Đấy chất xám mình quý vân vân
đấy cái tâm mình là một cái quý đấy Nói
chung là rất nhiều cái quý mình mình nên
đặt nó đúng chỗ các thứ thử còn tiền thì
thực ra là cái thứ mà mình dễ mất và
cũng dễ lấy lại lắm nên là thực ra đừng
đặt nặng
nó nếu mà giả sử mà tôi đánh cái Mọi
công sức của tôi vào tiền thì nó sẽ phải
rất rất có giá thế nên là tôi mới không
đánh và và nếu mà theo một cái đặt một
cái giá thế tôi cảm thấy là nó Thậm chí
còn làm giảm giá của cái công sức mình
bỏ ra hơn ấy nói chung là theo tôi quan
điểm như
từng kể mấy ông về cái định hướng rồi đó
là nếu có thời gian tôi tôi sẽ phải kiểu
cần dạy một cách bài bản kiểu tham gia
nhiều khóa học à học hết tất cả khóa học
này xong rồi đi dạy bài bản bên ft chẳng
hạn đấy
xong rồi sang bên spam để tổng hợp lại
cái khóa học kiểu các thứ thứ được bài
bản hơn xong rồi bài tập mọi thứ bên đấy
còn hỗ trợ đầu ra vân vân các thứ thứ
Hồi đấy tôi sẽ cố sẽ chia sẻ lại cho mấy
ông lại mấy cái playlist chất lượng
nhưng đương nhiên lúc đấy mấy không có
thể không cần nữa nhưng mà khóa sau cần
đấy tôi rất hiy vọng điều đấy sẽ thành
hiện thực sẽ đúng lội
em bị mất student có chên xong chuyển
qua nein cái nó quằn quằn là gì không
hiểu tốt hay xấu cơ tao tránh ngành đây
ngành này trầm cảm phết đừng trầm cảm
nữa bạn à đâu ngần đây tôi khuyên ngược
lại hãy trầm cảm lên bạn đừng có vui m
mãi vui mãi vui Kiểu gì nó sẽ đến lúc
buồn thôi đừng vui nữa hãy buồn đi Hãy
châm cảm đi rồi bạn sẽ nhìn đời
không phải màu hồng nữa nhưng mà chắc
chắn là nó sẽ khác đúng
không ừ Tức C Tôi cũng thường hay khuyên
mọi người là kiểu đừng đừng buồn nữa
đừng chầm cảm nữa đấy cũng được Cũng một
cái khuyên mà mọi người cứ kiểu bị nặng
nề nó
ấ bây giờ nếu tôi đang buồn mà có ai đó
ngồi quan tâm tôi nói ông ơi vui lên Có
khi tôi vui lên thật
đy đừng đừng nghĩ nhiều Thực ra tôi bảo
rồi nhỉ Có những thứ mình kiểm soát được
Có những thứ không đúng không ạ Cái mình
dễ kiểm soát được ấ không phải cảm xúc
của người khác không phải người khác nói
gì về mình cái đấy Mình không kiểm soát
được cái mình kiểm soát được chính là
cảm xúc của mình đấy lại một thứ mà ông
nào mà kiểm soát được cảm xúc nhá lý trí
hay nói chung là rất nhiều thứ của bản
thân mình ấy mà ông là làm chủ được ấy
thì lúc đấy thành công rất rất nhiều rồi
thành công rất nhiều Tôi nghĩ đa số ở
đây chả không chưa đến mức thành công ng
đâu Nên mới có thể ng ngồi nghe ở đây
tôi chém gió
đấy đi làm về orm hay sao ạ tôi không
hiểu câu này
gì trong thực tế vậy ông cũng không biết
trả lời conu này
định hưởng m vành gì playlist anh cần
như full stack Đúng rồi Tôi đang dạy
hướng v stack chính xác là thiên về back
end nhiều
tôi sẽ có có những cái bài tập gì đó tôi
sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn về hoặc là tôi gặp
vấn đề gì đó trên công ty tôi hướng dẫn
các bạn về equ trên sâu Còn không thì
thường thì cũng chẳng có đề nào lắm trừ
khi bây giờ đang tập đá ẽ chuẩn phải tập
trung code vào cái nốt cái web kia sau
đó thì về sau nếu mà về sau rất là rảnh
thì về sau sẽ làm hacker rank mấy cái
SQL
viên YouTube à Có gì gửi ít ly cà phê
Hồi trước Thực ra tôi từng tạo một cái
không biết mế ông biết cái C không nh
kiểu nó có cái kiểu kiểu give me
ca phe kiểu kiểu gửi tôi một tch trà một
tch cà phê ấ thôi từng đăng ký đấy nhưng
mà về sau tôi cũng ẩn đi hết rồi Nói
chung là tôi không muốn nhận cái gì đó
từ các bạn bằng hiện vật ch lắm Tình cảm
mọi thứ hay các thứ thứ thì ổn hơn hơn
hiện vật đương nhiên về sau nếu mà tôi
có vấn đề gì Tôi Vẫn Nhờ mấy ông mà
giống như kiểu lúc mà nick tôi bay này
tôi vẫn tác tất cả mọi người vào đ xem
ai hỗ trợ được tôi mà nghĩa là anh em
mình vẫn mang Thiên hướng là có gì cho
nhau được thì cho giúp nhau mặt nhiều
cái đừng nghĩ việc tiền bạc gì cả nó bị
nặng nề quá không nên không nên tiền bạc
hay tính toán gì cả nhẹ nhàng
cao đẳng anh học được không ạ trường cao
đẳng thời tôi học khác bây giờ rất nhiều
rồi n tôi khó chia sẻ được lắm chỉ biết
được là bây giờ tôi đang dạy ở trường à
đ tạ kiểu BCH hoa
Aptech bên này hiện tại cũng đang khá
tốt kể cả cho tủ Tôi có thể tôi sẽ không
còn dạy ở đây về sau nữa nhưng mà bên
này hiện tại tôi thấy đang khá tốt các
bạn có thể xem xét à Ở Hà Nội nhá Đấy
Bởi vì tôi thấy là ngoài nó cũng có bằng
cấp mọi thứ chứng chỉ có vẻ ổn bằng cấp
ở bên Bách Hoa không biết được là tuyển
sinh vào nó mọi thứ nó như nào Cái này
chắc bạn phải tìm hiểu thêm rồi không nm
rõ điều đấy nhưng mà Tại sao tôi bảo tốt
bởi vì kể cả cho dù tôi không còn dạy
đây nữa thì tôi thấy là thứ nhất là thầy
của tôi hồi trước làm chương trình đào
tạo thì bên sang bên này làm nên chương
trình đào tạo khá là ổn vài bản thứ hai
là các thầy ở đây tôi thấy là đều chẻ
tâm huyết đấy nên là tôi tự tin có thể
đề xuất thế thôi Cái gì Nói chung là tôi
thiên hướng của cái kênh này vẫn là cái
gì mà Tôi thấy hay tôi chia sẻ với ông
mấy ông với góc nhìn là với góc nhìn của
tôi và với kiểu toàn bộ cái tâm thật chứ
không phải vì gọi nhở vu lợi hay là vì
tôi được cái gì cả đúng
lập trình khác không ạ Ừ chuẩn là đáng
lẽ là đang định học Java các th thứ đấy
nhưng mà ô Quá nhiều thứ cần học không ạ
bởi vì tôi không hẳn định hướng là làm l
trình viên hoàn toàn mà về sau tôi sẽ đi
dậy và cũng như là đi emm diễn giả và
nói chung là định làm rất nhiều thứ nữa
t định học rất nhiều thứ nữa
Java để tôi nốt lại những cái thứ tôi
định
vào đã ghi vào để nhớ ghi vào là một
hình thức để mình nhớ lại mình thêm một
cái dấu ấn để nhớ
làm đi các bạn đôi khi nghĩ nghĩ nhiều
quả Mấy ông còn tự mình dọa mình n Thực
ra nó có vấn đề khó khăn gì đâu Anh
không lấy lại tài khoản Facebook nữa ạ à
Tôi có mới thc là tôi có mới a đặt mua
của một anh chicker ở trên YouTube à
trên tiktok khá là nổi mỗi tí tôi sẽ
dùng b này mở ra xem trong này có những
cái bài học các thứ những cái mẹo các
thứ Cái lỗi
956 cái khóa dạng khóa của tôi khá kiểu
anh ấy bảo quốc dân để tí tôi thử mở ra
xem tôi có thể mở tôi thử tìm hiểu xem
là có thể mở được Facebook không xem Nhớ
bật máy ảo nhé à Ok cảm ơn em bạn nhá
quên đấy
Ừ để
thì mới nên cài Đúng
rồi
thức Advance của của
SQL có có Index có view rồi mà cái
partition thì thực ra là tôi cũng muốn
thực ra là có những cái chuyên sâu hơn
Đúng bạn đang nói thêm cả những cái
chuyên sâu hơn nữa tôi chưa được đụng
đến thực tế bởi vì hồi những cái mà tôi
chia sẻ mấy ông ở trong cái phần nâng
cao đấy nó là h tôi còn dạy ở trên
trường và tôi có tài liệu tôi đọc nên là
tôi kiểu nghiên cứu cái đấy rất là kỹ
hơn nên tôi có thể chia sẻ được Còn
những cái mà ông vừa nói thì tôi mới chỉ
đọc qua tôi cũng còn chưa áp dụng thực
tế bao giờ để mà khó mà thể chia sẻ dạy
mấy ông được nhưng mà cũng là là một cái
đó là thực tế thực tế cũng tùy dừng lúc
có thể áp dụng được thực tế là mình cần
tối ưu nhất là tối Yu nhất về cái câu
truy vấn select thôi chứ mấy kia thực sự
là không cần kiểu nắm rõ nó
sandbox Hình như Win 11 mới có
không phải máy ảo đâu nó chỉ môi trường
ạo
thôi em đang bị 956 để tí tôi mở được
thì tôi hỗ trợ mấy
rồi
này yeah
fail set đ yeah hay là do cái cái phiên
bản này của anh kia giới hạn với cái
sunbox này
nhỉ th tí thử tra cả lỗi này
xem có gì mấy ông tự tra về cách mở
Windows sunbox nhá Đúng rồi phải mở thủ
công lên mới
Ờ thường mở run Quick admin thấy mà bùm
vẫn không được sẽ đi này CH để tôi cho
mã lỗi
sau Uy tôi trả lời Mấy ông nãy th khẳn
luôn giọng rồi rõ hôm nay buổi tâm sự
thôi chứ không phải là buổi trả lời câu
hỏi đâu Tôi đã cố xóa cái tiêu đề trả
lời câu hỏi rồi có gì đấy đây trả lời
nốt ông này em sắp đi ra Hà Nội trên
Ninh để thực tập công ty em ở xa quá lần
đầu đi xa nhà không biết Hà Nội khó sống
không anh
nhỉ Anh chưa đủ uống đủ nước Ok tiếp Hà
Nội khó sống không Nếu mà trả lời bằng
cái thằng sinh ra ở Hà Nội thì thì nó
không không khách quan đúng không để mà
trả lời theo những bạn của tôi từ tỉnh
lên hoặc là thậm chí là hẳn một thành
phố khác giống như là Sài Gòn hay Đà
Nẵng ra trả lời thì câu trả lời vẫn là
không Hà Nội à đâu nhờ Câu trả lời là có
Có à Khó sống không anh nhỉ là có hay
không
nhỉ Có khó sống đúng rồi đấy khó sống
khó sống ở đây là như nào nó là cũng khá
là nhộn nhịp xô bồ
và nó không kể Mở thoải mái như
là ở Sài Gòn nó cũng có cái kiểu dạng Là
Dạng như nó nửa nàng nửa mỡ như kiểu à
đương nhiên là ông ở trọ hay cái gì gì
đó thì thì nó đỡ hơn chứ nếu mà ông mà
kiểu có họ hàng ở đây chẳng hạn người ta
nói các thứ thứ giả sử Ông lên ở nhờ
kiểu họ hàng ấy thì họ để ý họ nói các
thứ gì cũng khó nghe có tùy từng người
thoải mái thôi chứ ra họ để bụng khó
không thoải mái sờ Lợi
lắm
là về ăn uống thứ hai là
về sinh hoạt vài cái nhưng mà Đấy trong
thì điều kiện cho người có điều kiện một
tí chứ không phải con người không có
điều kiện thì tính ra trên này mọi thứ
nó vẫn cạch tranh nó vẫn
kiểu có cơ hội cái là mọi người tranh và
bu bu lấy Vân Vân nó không dễ dàng lắm
nên là
tôi sẽ không dùng từ là dễ sống nhưng
mà gọi là khi mà ông quen được cái Nhịp
độ rồi ấ quen được nhịp độ rồi thứ nhất
là khi mà tôi sang tỉnh khác ấy Tôi cảm
thấy kiểu nó bị tẻ nhạt đấy kiể Kiểu tôi
nghĩa sang tình khác sang kiểu đặc biệt
là kiểu hồi mà tôi về kiểu quê chẳng hạn
à thì tôi sẽ kiểu thấy kiểu nó bị chầm
chậm quá tôi lại không quen th cảu thế
Tôi nghĩ là cũng lắm về sau tôi về hillu
thì tôi mới về đấy đấy chẳng hạn thế
nghĩa là thực sự không thích kiểu so bồ
nữa thì mới về đấy
thành ra tôi cảm thấy là tôi bắt được
cái nhịp đấy ở Hà Nội rồi tính ra là Hà
Nội ngoài việc chi phí này xong rồi cả
điều kiện sống kiểu là môi trường nó
cũng kiểu đúng nghĩa là độc hại
Có tôi là một người rất là yêu Hà Nội và
sinh ra lớn lên Hà Nội nhá
Tôi tôi vẫn phải thừa nhận tất cả những
cái điều đấy
tôi cũng thừa nhận chính bản thân tôi là
con người cũng độc hại
nữa tôi đang góp phận độc hại ở chong nó
nói chung là tôi vẫn khẳng định là nó là
môi trường đủ để cạnh tranh để mà bạn
phát triển bạn phải chấp nhận khó thì
bạn sẽ bước phá Còn nếu không thì bạn sẽ
cảm thấy là nó quá ngột ngạt nó quá rất
nhiều thứ dùng từ quá cũng đúng bởi vì
đến cả khí hậu cả thời tiết nó cũng quá
lạnh quá Nóng quá chẳng có cái gì bình
thường đây cả đấy Thật sự như thế chiu á
Ông thấy Hà Nội chiu á Ông thấy ở đâu ấ
kiểu thỉnh thoảng nó mới gọi là gọi là
như này
ông tận hưởng một chút cái chiu trong
cái sự
sự nhột nhịp Sự đầy đủ thứ khó chịu đấy
cả nồm nữa vân vân
u Kể ra mình kể ra Khác không Khác gì
mình đang đi chửi cái nơi mình sinh ra
cả nhưng mà nhưng mà tôi gọi
bạn nữ nào đang nghe thì tạm tắt mic ạ à
đâ tạm tắt tiếng ạ à Tôi thường tôi lại
nhớ lại cái câu hồi trước tôi từng đọc
cái này như ở nhà nhà văn nào ấy chứ
không phải tôi tự nh tự chế đâu nhá Nó
kiểu thường hai ví Hà Nội như một người
cô gái đấy cô gái
với như một người con gái kiểu dạng kiểu
dạng à thiếu nữ tuổi đôi m à kiểu thế
kiểu xinh đẹp kiểu còn nhă sắc các thứ
thứ nên thành ra
kiểu
sớm nắng chều mưa vân vân đủ kiểu nói
chung là cũng khiến mình không dễ dàng
gì cho lắm
đấy cũng rất là mệt đấy nhưng mà bù lại
thì khi mà khi mà mình đã đủ cố gắng các
thứ thứ rồi ấ mình sẽ nhìn thấy được cái
nép đẹp đấy mình sẽ cảm thấy nó có gì đó
cuốn kiểu kiểu
nói ám chỉ gì chưa nĩ ám chỉ là kiểu có
có thể là những cái tỉnh khác Thanh
Thanh Bình đấy Kiểu nó không nhận nhịp
không kiểu xối xả như đấy thì có kiểu
thế không vũi Đôi khi thấy thế không vũi
thích gái hư cơ thích gái kiểu nhõm nhẽo
tí cơ thích gái
kiểu g kó dễ một tí cơ đấy Đấy nó cũng
giống Hà Nội nó kiểu thế nghĩa là ví dụ
ví dụ điển hình ở buổi sáng thì ông sẽ
thấy rất là nóng rất là khó chịu thì ông
sẽ trân trọng vào lúc buổi tối kiểu chơi
mát mát tí ông cảm thấy Ui nhẹ nhàng hơn
hẳn lại thế thích thích hong rõ kiểu thế
sau một ngày kiểu các
ngỡ có một vài cái em không nên sợ tôi
thường nói đi nói lại mấy ông rồi mấy
ông đừng nên sợ một cái gì cả m em chỉ
mấy ông sợ là mấy ông đ thua chính bản
thân mình rồi nghĩa nghĩa là mấy ông còn
chưa trải mà tôi Thư ấy nói cái câu là
mấy ông phải thử đã đúng không m con
chưa chải mấy ông đã sợ đúng
mình luôn Chuẩn bị tâm lý mình nên Đương
nhiên mình nên luôn chuẩn bị mọi thứ bao
của tâm lý nhưng mà mình đừng nên sợ gì
cả đúng
chính mất chính bản thân ông trước rồi
chưa làm gì đã chưa làm gì đ đã trùn
bước rồi thì làm sao mình kiểu tự tin
được đúng không ạ Đấy C thoải mái đi học
vẽ phân tích vẽ rd nhưng khó
hiểu Tôi không dễ hỏi rd lắm Tôi cũng
không biết khuyên ông kiểu gì
Ờ cái này em hỏi trên discord nhá Anh sẽ
cố được rồi em Em cố em em nhớ hỏi luôn
nhá Không anh quên đấy em hỏi trên
discord server discord em tạo một cái th
một cái th rồi TC anh vào đúng không ạ
đấy để anh sẽ tự cứ coi như là đây là
một cái cơ hội đi cơ hội để cho anh a
cũng sẽ tự học nói chung là kiểu đôi khi
là mình mình tự học cho chính mình thì
đôi khi mình ngại mà đúng không Cứ cho
thế x bây giờ em hỏi anh sẽ phải có cớ
để mà Anh học để anh sẽ giảng lại hướng
dẫn lại cho các bạn Ok đúng không ạ buổi
sau nhé À nghĩa Buổi sau anh sẽ chữa như
em cứ hỏi luôn em t Anh vào luôn biết
cách tạo th chưa biết cái server discord
chưa trong cái mô tả ấy đấy các bạn cứ
làm nhá Anh dùng LP gì vậy ạ Tôi dùng
thb
X1 không nhớ đời bao nhiêu nữa đấy như
đại khai thể Ok Cảm ơn về Lề khuyên ok
Nói chung là bây giờ tôi nói khản giọng
rồi một tiếng rưỡi rồi tôi bây giờ tôi
còn n phải kiểu tìm cách lấy lại
Facebook đã có gì tôi sẽ liên hệ mấy ôm
sau ạ à Nhờ
Có gì tôi sẽ buổi sau nhá chắc là phải
tuần nữa Bởi
vì thứ năm là công ty tôi liên hoan
không say không về nên thành ra là tôi
sẽ cố không say như tôi sẽ không về à
Nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ về đấy ok Facebook
bị anh bị sao ạ Facebook tôi chạy demo
bị khóa mà OK nhá xare cách mở khóa mấy
ông cứ thấy là Facebook tôi mở được thì
mấy ông inbox TH thôi còn nếu mà thấy
Facebook tôi vẫn còn đóng thì chứng tỏ
tôi chưa làm được đơn giản không
ạ đơn giản mà đúng không Việ thật Việt
thật nhá Khi nào thấy Facebook tôi mởi
được thì nhắn tôi đấy Chào mấy